today business analysts and data
scientists increasingly need to clean
standardize and transform diverse data
sets but the process is known to be
difficult and time-consuming transform
data by example is an Excel add-in that
allows Excel users to easily discover
reuse and extend existing data
transformations on their own without the
need to write code transform data by
example is powered by a back-end service
running and Azure that can index
publicly available data transformation
functions in the form of source code
dll's and web services you can also
extend the capabilities of the service
by providing it with your own custom
data transformation functions then for
given data transformation tasks
transform data by example infers from a
handful of input-output examples how to
combine these functions to obtain a
program that realizes that task let me
show you how the system works suppose I
want to standardize the day time data in
column a to the format in column B so
that I can do subsequent analytics based
on the day of the week
observe that the values in column a
appear in many different formats for
this task I only need to type in a few
examples like the ones in column B to
specify the exact output format I want I
click on an empty cell in the output
column and once I click on the get
transformations button in the Excel
add-in it will talk to our back-end
service which will search over thousands
of functions that we indexed and compose
a program that produces the desired
output in this case we find system
daytime dot parse as the top-ranked
function which is a standard dotnet
function if we click on the suggested
transformation it populates the result
column with the output produced by the
program now suppose we want a slightly
different format
switching the order of the weekday and
the day of the month transform data by
example can provide this as well
in the second example we can see that
the name column contains a mix of
different formats such as first name
last name or last name comma first name
as well as suffixes and titles if we
want to standardize this to the format
of last name comma first name removing
all titles and suffixes we again use a
few output examples such as the ones in
column B in this case we signed a
program using a function from a github
library that can parse different types
of names as we can see transform data by
example complete this task perfectly
the next example is to standardize us
addresses into the format of city state
and zip code notice that some of the
information such as the state and the
zip code is actually missing from some
rows in the input the first suggestion
given by our code actually uses a Python
package that invokes the Bing Maps API
and obtains the missing information in
this way this example illustrates that
transform data by example can leverage
powerful and domain-specific web
services such as the Bing Maps API to
make the otherwise complex task of
address parsing and standardization much
simpler
even though transform data by example
can already handle many important
domains out-of-the-box
in different industries and application
domains you have domain-specific and
proprietary data transformation
functions that the service has never
seen before and therefore doesn't
support as yet extensibility is really
important in the case shown here our
task is to extract browser information
from what is known as user agent strings
transform data by example doesn't
support this type of transformation
out-of-the-box and therefore you will
get nothing returned but we can extend
its capabilities by adding a new web
service to its collection we went online
and found the web service user agent
string comm that takes the user agent
string and parses it to return a JSON
object containing all relevant fields in
the user agent string to make the
service available to transform data by
example we click on add my service and
type in the URL with a single example
query of how to invoke the web service
now if we try the same task a suggestion
is returned which is from the web
service we just ingested that can parse
different user agent strings
you
in summary transform data by example is
a powerful data transformation engine
that is user-friendly out-of-the-box
transform data by example comes with
transformation functions crawled from
sources like github net and stack
overflow for common domains like dates
names addresses and phone numbers like
web search engines the transform data by
example service will continue to improve
its quality as more people use it and we
plan to improve the service over time
with new updates and enhanced features
so give it a try and stay tuned we
strive to make your data transformation
problems really easy to solve